اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام في هذه التغطيه
المستمره لتداعيات زلزال تركيا وسوريا في
نهايه الاسبوع الاول بعد الزلزال تصلنا
هذه الصور من مدينه غازي عنتاب التركيه
فيها تستمر اعمال الانقاذ والبحث عن
ناجينا تحت حطام المباني المنهاره
ومن اعزاز تردنا هذه الصور من شمال الريف
حلب حيث تواصل فرق دفاع مدني سوري رفع
الانقاض بحثا عن ضحايا محاصرين تحتها
والامال في العثور على احياء تتضاءل
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
شمال غربي سوريا مساعدات تتعثر بعد سبعه
ايام من الزلزال وسجال سياسي يطيل
الانتظار الامم المتحده تقر بخزلان
المتضررين ومفوضيه شؤون اللاجئين تقول
للجزيره ان معبر باب الهوى غير كاف لايصال
الاحتياجات وبين ريفي حلب وشمال ادلب
كاميرا الجزيره ترصد يوميات فرق الدفاع
المدني وسط جهود انقاذ يقودها نفاذ الوقت
ونقص المعدات
على الجانب الثاني من الحدود مشهد تركي
مماثل في الدمار ومختلف في تدفق المساعدات
عدد قتل الزلزال يقارب 30 الفا الامم
المتحده تحذر عدد الضحايا قد يتضاعف ورغم
تضاؤل الامل فرق الانقاذ تعثر على ناجين
بعد مضي اكثر من 150 ساعه على الزلزال
بعد انهيار وتضرر اكثر من 25 الف مبنى
جراء الزلزال تحقيقات تشتبه في مسؤوليه
بشريه في انهيار مباني جراء عدم التقيد
بالمعايير وسلطات التركيه تامر باعتقال
اكثر من 100 شخص والجزيره ترصد ابعاد
القضيه وملامح التحقيقات من ديار بكر
مع اقتراب الزلزال من اجمالي يومه السابع
وصل عدد القتل الى نحو
4500 في سوريا بالاضافه الى الاف الاصابات
قافله امميه تضم 10 شاحنات دخلت الى شمال
غرب سوريا عبر معبر باب الهوى مفوضيه
الشؤون اللاجئين تقول للجزيره ان معبره
باب الهوى غير كاف لايصال الاحتياجات اما
الامم المتحده وفي تغريده لمارتن غرفس
وكيل الامين العام للامم المتحده للشؤون
الانسانيه فاقرت بخذلان المتضررين من
الزلزال في الشمال السوري
في مدينه حارم بادلب اختفت البيوت لتحل
محلها خيام هنا وهناك لكن الفرق بين عدد
البيوت التي تحولت الى ركام والعدد القليل
من الخيام التي نصبت شاسع جدا هنا تولد
احساس لدى الناس ان العالم تركهم يواجهون
مصيرهم وحدهم بعد الزلزال
اول قافله ارسلتها الامم المتحده عبر معبر
باب الهوى للمتضررين شمال غربي سوريا دخلت
بعد سته ايام من الزلزال والثانيه دخلت
بعد اليوم السابع قافلتان في سبعه ايام
لمواجهه كارثه مدمره سوريون رسموا العلم
الاممي مقلوبا وكتبوا عليه الامم المتحده
خذلتنا تلخص الصوره الشعور العامه في شمال
غربي سوريا يدعمها كلام وكيل الامين
العامل للامم المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه
ماتين الذي قال ان المجتمع الدولي خذل من
يعيشون في شمال غربي سوريا وانهم محقون في
شعورهم بان المجتمع الدولي تخلى عنهم ودعا
الى معالجه ما وصفه بالفشل في اسرع وقت
ممكن اما المبعوث الاوروبي الى سوريا فقد
دعا دمشق الى عدم تاسيس ملف المساعدات
الانسانيه ورفضت اتهام الاتحاد الاوروبي
بالتقصير في تقديم ما يكفي من المساعدات
السوريين ماذا يقصد المبعوث الاوروبي
بتاسيس المساعدات هل هو اتهام مبطن للنظام
السوري بمنع وصول المساعدات الى مناطق
المعارضه رغم اعلانه السماح بذلك حتى الان
لم ترد اي معلومات تشير الى ان مساعدات
دوليه عبرت من مناطق نفوذ النظام الى
مناطق المعارضه
في دمشق تتحدث منظمه الصحه العالميه عن
انتظار موافقه من الطرف الاخر للعبور الى
مناطق شمال غربي سوريا لم يحصل السوريون
في هذه المناطق على المساعده لانقاذ من
يمكن انقاذهم في الايام التي ثلاث الزلزال
باعتراف الجميع الان المجتمع الدولي امام
اختبار اكبر فكارثه الزلزال تكشف عن وجوه
قبيحه عده تحتاج مساعدات على مدى شهور
وربما سنوات
كثيرون مثل محمد حاج حسين فقدوا بيوتهم
تقول الامم المتحده ان خمسه ملايين
وثلاثمائه الف سوري اصبحوا دون ماوى بسبب
الزلزال قضى في الزلزال من قضى وبقي عدد
مخيف من الجرحى والايتام والارامل
سيحتاجون مساعدات هائله بعيدا عن حسابات
السياسه
تواصل فرق الدفاع المدني السوري عمليات
انتشال الضحايا من تحت الانقاض في عده
بلدات برفي حلب وادلب شمال غربي سوريا
وتوجه فرق الانقاذ صعوبات عديده ابرزها
نقص المعدات واستنزاف قدرات الكوادر
العامله
ادار العالم ظهره لهم فكانوا وحيدين في
وجه الكارثه
كارثه سبقتها مخاطر واهوال واجهها عبد
ورفاقه في الدفاع المدني شمال سوريا لكن
كارثه الزلزال اليوم انهكته ورفاقه وفاقت
قدراتهم
انا بوقت الزلزال كنت مناوي بعزاز الحمد
لله استجبنا
للناس المتضرره من الزلزال
والتحقنا بمدينه جنديرس لانه كان الضرر
فيها اكبر من هيك طلبوا مؤازرات الاغلب من
جميع الدفاع المدني
وكان في ضحايا كتير تحت الانقاض وابنيه
كتير مدمره
والله عيالي ضليت يومين ما اعرف عنه شي
يومين ما اعرف عنه شيء بس انا مامن يعني
انه اهلي بحده
لا احد هنا يترقب خروج ناجم من تحت
الانقاض انتهت مرحله الصمت وفقد عبد
ورفاقه الامل في العثور على ناجين لكن
مهمه انتشار الضحايا لم تنته بعد
يواصلون العمل تاره بايديهم العاريه وتاره
اخرى بادوات خفيفه
وبما توفر من معدات ثقيله
تمر الساعات وينقضي اليوم ولا اثر للجثث
التي ابتلعها الركام
بعد اربعه ايام من العمل المتواصل يتوزع
فريق الدفاع المدني بعضهم يتابع العمل
واخرون يذهبون لاخذ قسط من الراحه
[موسيقى]
ان كانوا في دوامه المخاطر فهم عرضه لها
مرحبا بابا
في هذه السياره تقضي عائلته يوميات النزوح
بعد ان تصدع منزلهم
الله ربي يسلمك ويرضى عليك يا ابي هنا
ينام اطفاله لكنهم اليوم ظلوا حتى ساعه
متاخره من الليل يرقبون عوده والدهم يعلم
الاب انها لن تكون الا ساعه قليله سيبقى
الاطفال بعدها وحدهم في السياره ويبقى
الاب ورفاقه وحدهم في مواجهه الكارثه عمرو
حلب الجزيره ريفو
الينا من اعزاز في ريف حلب مراسل الجزيره
محمد الجزائري ومعنى من غازي عنتاب مراسل
الجزيره منتصر ابو نبوت مرحبا بكما محمد
الجزائري من ريف حلب اذا على مشارف ان
تطوي هذه الكارثه اسبوعها الاول كيف يتحول
العمل على الارض
في الحقيقه اسبوع مضى مليء بالمصاعب مليء
بالتحديات ان كان على الصعيد الفرق الدفاع
المدني والانقاذ او على صعيد الفرق الطبيه
حقيقه الماساه والخطر يبدا وتتكشف وجوهه
يوما بعد يوم مع مضوي هذه الايام الخطر
وسائل الاكبر هي بعد مضي هذه الايام
السبعه وما زال هناك حسب مقاله وحده تنسيق
الدعم المئات ما زالوا تحت الانقاض هؤلاء
الذين يقول الفرق الدفاع المدني انه لم
يعد هناك امل او الامل ضئيل جدا بخروج
احدهم او بعضهم من تحت الانقاض على قيد
الحياه هذه الارقام التي تتضاعف يوما بعد
يوم اعداد الضحايا الذين فقدوا حياتهم في
وحده تنسيق الدعم قالت ان هناك اكثر من
4300 شخص قتلوا جراء هذا الزلزال بالاضافه
الى اكثر من 5,700
شخص هم مصابون نحن عن ارقام كبيره حقيقه
بالمقابل على جهود
جهود جدا ضعيفه في الشمال السوري على جميع
الاصعده ان كان على الدفاع المدني
بالاضافه الى الكوادر الطبيه التي هي
اساسا تعاني ضعف وقله من الخبرات او
التخصصات المحدده الدفاع المدني لديه
الامكانيات ولكن هناك اكثر من 500 وخمسين
بناء مدمر بشكل كامل وفرق الدفاع المدني
تعمل على انتشال والبحث عن الضحايا تحت
هذه النقاط بالاضافه الى ان المنظمات
الانسانيه تعمل بما تستطيع وتقدم ما
تستطيع للاهالي ولكن هناك الازمه التي
ستكون تتكشف وجوهها بعد مضيء الايام هي
البحث عن ماوى وبحث عن والبحث عن منازل
للاهالي الذين فقدوا منازلهم او تضررت
جراء هذا الزلزال وتصدعت ولم تعد تصلح
للسكن اعداد كبيره التي فقدت منازلها بحسب
احصائيات وحده تنسيق الدعم ان هناك اكثر
من 5 الاف منزل مدمر بشكل جزئي ولا يصلح
لي السكن علاوه عن 1700 منزل بناء طابقي
مدمر بشكل كامل وخمسه الاف وسبعمئه بناء
مدمر بشكل جزئي ولا يصلح السكن نحن نتحدث
عن الاف العائلات التي باتت مهجره بلا
منزل ولا بماوى تفترش بعضها الطرقات او
تنتظر
وتفترش الطرقات وتنتظر
ابسط ما يمكن من المنظمات المحليه خيمه
تؤويهم
وتسترهم في هذا البرد وبهذه هذه الاوضاع
الانسانيه الماساويه بالاضافه الى ان
الماسه ستتكشف بعد ايام هؤلاء الاعداد
الكبيره التي تخطط لربما احد عشر الفا
بحسب الاحصائيات 11 الف عائله فقدت ماواها
وباتت بلا ماوى هؤلاء العائلات يبحثون
سيبحثون عن مخيم ايقان انشاء مخيمات
سيتزداد بحسب مقاله المنظمات المحليه ان
هناك احتماليه كبيره لازدياد المخيمات
العشوائيه
المناطق على اطراف المدن وهذه مخيمات التي
هي اساسا تفتقر لبنى تحتيه وخدمات حقيقه
الماساه كبيره امام بالمقابل هناك ضعف دعم
دولي
وادخال المساعدات الدوليه
لمساعده هؤلاء الاهالي الذين هم تضرروا
بشكل كبير خلال هذا الزلزال اليك اشكرك من
ريف حلب محمد الجزائري وقبل ان انتقل الى
منتصر ابونا بوت في غازي عنتاب نشير الى
ان مرصد اذا اعلن مرصد الزلازل التركي قبل
قليل عن تسجيل ثلاث هزات ارتداديه تتراوح
قوتها بين 4.1 واربعه فاصل سبعه على مقياس
ريختر في مدينه كهرمان مرش ما ادى الى
ايقاف مؤقت لاعمال الانقاذ قرب مبانئ
متداعيه في حين اعلنت هيئه المسح
الجيولوجي الامريكي تسجي تسجيل هزه ارضيه
تبلغ شدتها 4.9
على مقياس ريختر في ولايه ملاطيا التركيه
بالاضافه الى 12 هزرتديه اخرى في تركيا
وشمال غرب سوريا في الساعه القليله
الماضيه
لكن ذلك لم يمنع من العثور على ناجين بعد
كل هذه الايام بعد سبعه ايام تمكنت فرق
الانقاذ في مدينه هاتاي المنكوبه من انقاذ
امراه مسنه بعد 152 ساعه
وبعد 140 ساعه انتشرت فرق الانقاذ الطفل
حمزه ذا سبعه اشهر
مثلها خرج حيين ايضا من تحت الانقاض بعد
سبعه ايام
[موسيقى]
الى غازي عنتاب حيث مراسل الجزيره منتصر
ابو نبوت منتصر ماذا عن الوضع الان في
غازي عنتاب كيف يعني ما هو الجديد الذي
يطرا على عمليات الانقاذ والاغاثه بعد مضي
سبعه ايام على وقوع الكارثه
يعني نحن في ساعات حاسمه متعلقه على
الصعيد الانقاذ وايضا على صعيد الاغاثه
بالنسبه للانقاذ نحن نتحدث عن يعني امال
ضعيفه بخروج عدد كبير من الناجين هذا لا
يعني انهم لم يخرجوا اليوم سجل في مدينه
غازي عنتاب اخراج يعني شخص بعد نحو مئه
وسته وخمسين ساعه من تحت الانقاذ في مدينه
نورداغ هذه تتبع اداريا لولايه غازي عنتاب
اما على الصعيد الاغاثي فان السلطات تعمل
على يعني احتواء هذا الامر واعاده
الطمانينه للاهالي وذلك من خلال رفع عدد
الخيام التي نصبتها يعني في مدينه
الاصلاحيه التي ضربها هذا الزلزال يوجد
اكثر من 5000 خيمه في ملعب هذه المدينه
طبعا هذه المدينه مدمره بشكل كامل
والمباني فيها جميعها اعتقد انها بحاجه
الى هدم لان ان لم تكن مدمره فتكون يعني
متداعيه لان التشققات
الدمار الجزئيه كبير جدا نحن ايضا في احد
هذه المخيمات لكننا في مدينه غازي عنتاب
وسط مدينه غازي عنتاب يمكننا مشاهده هذه
الصور هؤلاء الاشخاص قد يعني تقريبا
استقروا في هذا المكان بعد سبعه ايام
وايضا بالقرب من هنا نصب قبل قليل خيام
خاصه في التوزيع وكانت بلديه غازي عنتاب
قالت ان عمليه تقديم المساعدات وعمليه
تقديم الطعام ستنتقل الى الاحترافيه اكثر
لانها في بدايتها كانت على جاءت على جاءت
على عجل فلذلك لم يكن هناك بعض التنظيم في
بعض الامور ولذلك هي الان تسعى الى احتواء
هذا الامر اما عن ولايه غازي عنتاب
فالولايه تحدثت عن
ارسال الفرق الفنيه الى المباني في كل
مدينه غازي عنتاب لتحديد صلاحيه هذه
المباني اذا كانت هذه المباني هي بحاجه
الى يعني هدم او بحاجه الى ترميم او ان
صالحه للعيش لذلك يعني اطلقوا موقع
الكترونيا يمكن للمواطن من خلاله معرفه
حال المبنى الذي يعيش فيه وبناء عليه قالت
اذا كان هذا المبنى غير متضرر وهو ظهرت
النتيجه ان هذا المبنى غير متضرر يمكن
يمكن للمواطنين ان يعودوا الى منازلهم لكن
المواطنين هنا يعني لا زالوا خائفين من
هذا الزلزال خصوصا مع الهزات الارتاليه
التي تسجل والتي سجلت ايضا اليوم ونشعر
بها في غازي عنتاب الارتداديه التي تكون
حتى في مدينه اخرى نشعر فيها نحن في غازي
عنتاب وهناك ذات ارتداديه في غازي عنتاب
نفسها هذا الامر يصعب الامر يصعب الوضع
على المدنيين الذين يعني يرغبون في العوده
الى منازلهم لكنهم شاهدوا زلزال الاول وهم
خائفون من هذا الزلزال ايضا نتحدث عن
عمليه ايقاف
للمقاولين وبعض اصحاب الشركات الذين هم
اصحاب للابنيه التي تهدمت هذا اللقاء يعني
هو بالنسبه للحكومه التركيه سيكون ما بعده
عمليه تحقيق
اذا ما كان هؤلاء الاشخاص مرتبطين بعمليات
فساد في قضيه البناء ام لا وهذا الامر
يعني هو ضمن الوضع الذي اعلن قانون
الطوارئ الذي اعلن في المناطق المنكوبه
والتي يعني على اثرها تدخل الجيش التركي
في عمليات المساعده وعمليات الانقاذ
واستلمه الكثير من المواقع لحمايتها وايضا
بعد انتشار عمليات السرقه التي تحدث عنها
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ايضا ولايه
عنتاب تحدثت عن تقديم الجيش التركي
لمساعدات لخريه كان يصعب الوصول اليها
بسبب تصدع الطرقات المؤديه اليها وقالت
الولايه ان تلك القرى تضررت ايضا من هذا
الزلزال وتم توزيع اليها الخيام بالاضافه
الى الاغذيه وان هذا ان الوضع في تركيا
المناطق اصبح يعني نسبيا مستقر ايضا
المدارس اجلت حتى واحد مارس واحد اذار
القادم وهذا التمديد يعني قد يستمر ايضا
بسبب صعوبه الامر وايضا الجامعات ست تتحول
الى
يعني التعليم عن بعد اون لاين وذلك
لاستخدام السكن الجامعي لواء العائلات
وتجهيز هذا السكن حتى يمكن لهذه العائلات
يعني ان تسكن فيه ويمكن الاستفاده من هذا
السكن لاحتواء هذه الازمه التي كانت كبيره
وكانت فاجعتها
اشكرك جزيل الشكر من غازي عنتاب مراسلنا
منتصر ابو نبوت حتى الساعه
مع تراجع الامال بالعثور على ناجين يتحول
عمل القوه البيضاء في شمال شرق سوريا الى
انتشال الجثث ورفع الانقاض وتلك مهمه
تتعقد اكثر في ضوء غياب اي مساعدات فعليه
من الخارج واعتماد فرق الانقاذ على
امكاناتها المحدوده والمستنزفه بعد اسبوع
من العمل الشاق
كثير من الموتى قليل من الاحياء تلك هي
المعادله الان في المناطق المنكوبه بعد
مضي اسبوع على كارثه الزلزال في شمال غربي
سوريا تدخل مهمه فرق الانقاذ مرحله
الاحباط والياس فهي الان تكاد تنحصر في
انتشال الجثث ورفع الانقاظ وحده تنسيق
الدعم التي تتولى استلام المساعدات
وتوزيعها في تلك المناطق اكدت ان عدد
القتلى تخطى اربعه الاف بينما يقترب عدد
الجرح والمصابين من ثمانيه الاف وهي حصيله
غير نهائيه حيثما يزال مئات الاشخاص
عالقين تحت الانقاض فيما لا يقل عن 90
مبنى منهارا
عوامل كثيره جعلت الكارثه هناك بهذا السوء
منها عدم وصول اي فرق اغاثه خارجيه او
معدات حفر في الوقت المناسب ولا حتى بعد
فوات الاوان كما ان الزلزال ضرب اكثر من
100 موقع يضم كل منها مباني ومنازل بكثافه
سكانيه متفاوته فضلا عن ان المنطقه التي
يتكدس فيها مئات الاف النازحين الفارينه
من هجمات النظام السوري كانت اصلا في ظروف
سيئه قبل الزلزال
قائمه الاحتياجات طويله وتتصدرها طلبات
عاجله لاكثر من مئه فرقه انقاذ لدعم فرق
الدفاع المدني المحلي التي يعمل فيها
حاليا اقل من الف متطوع كما تشمل
الاحتياجات العاجله اكثر من 400 اليه
مختلفه المهام والوظائف من شاحنات لنقل
الركام واليات للحفر والنبش وجرافات
واليات اخرى اما متطلبات السكان بمن فيهم
الناجون والمصابون والذين باتوا بلا ماوى
فتبدو اكثر استعجالا وفق نداء وحده تنسيق
الدعم يحتاجون اكثر من 100 الف وجبه طعام
يوميا ونحو 160 الف قطعه من الاغطيه
والمفارش فضلا عن اكثر من سته ملايين لتر
من وقود التدفئه في مناخ شتوي بالغ القسوه
في غضون ذلك استطلع فريق من الاطباء
المتطوعين في الهلال الاحمر القطري
الاوضاع الميدانيه في مناطق شمال غرب
سوريا بعد عبوره من معبر باب الهوى
الحدودي مع تركيا اضاف المراسل ان الفريق
مكون من 12 طبيبا من مختلف التخصصات لدعم
القطاع الطبي في المناطق المنكوبه جراء
الزلزال
هدفنا ووصلنا هنا الى باب الهوى في الجانب
السوري معنى فريق طبي متواجد معنا من عدد
من الاطباء
متخصصين في عدد من التخصصات المهمه حقيقه
تخصصات في الجراحه العامه
بتخصص بالاطفال ايضا للنساء ايضا بجراحات
التجميليه ايضا عندنا طبيب نفسي ايضا
موجود معنا فكل هذه التخصصات صراحه جزاهم
الله خير تبرعوا ضمن فريق الهلال انه
ياتوا يقدموا هذا الدعم الصحي
للمحتاجين داخل الاراضي السوريه معنا
معدات تم شحنها من دوله قطر سيتم ادخالها
ان شاء الله الى الداخل السوري فان شاء
الله باذن الله يعني او ايضا عندنا فرق
اخرى ايضا راح تاتي تباعا
ينضم الينا من ريفي ادلب احمد يازجي عضو
مجلس اداره الدفاع المدني السوري مرحبا بك
سيد احمد عمليا عندما يتحدث وكيل الامين
العام للشؤون الانسانيه للامم المتحده عن
ان المجتمع الدولي خذل السوريين عمليا ما
هي الكلفه التي ترتبت على هذا الخذلان وفق
متابعتك ومشاهداتك على الارض
عن هذا الخزلان هو الدم دم شعب عاما كثيرا
قبل حدوث هذا الزلزال وانا اثناء حدوث
الزلزال توقع الكثيرين ان يكون هناك
استجابه عادي لوطارئه من قبل الامم
المتحده والتلبيه نداءات التي اطلقناها
نحن كثره الدفاع مدني او بالاضافه
للمنظمات المحليه اللي اطلقت ايضا عده
نزاءات للاستعداد في ارسال مساعدات طارئه
وعادمه ان كان لفراق الدفاع المدني
العامله او بالاضافه الى المدنيين منتظرين
ولكن كان الاجدر ان يكون هناك
مساعدات عادله الدفاع المدني لكي نتمكن من
مساعده جميع العالقين من تحت الانصاب وهم
على قيد الحياه ناسف ان نقول ان هذا
الخزلان نتج عنه ضحايا اضافيه
الان هو وعد بانه سينكب على تبديل هذا
الوضع عمليا ما الذي قاله لكم بماذا وعد
قال بانه كان هناك اخطاء كان هناك
بطء ايضا في الدراسه او وعد ان يكون في
الايام القادمه بعض المساعدات التي سوف
تاتي الى شمال المغرب سوريا
بالاضافه ان هناك بعض الدول التي قدمت
مساعدات على سبيل المثال في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه بالاضافه الى قطر
والعراق التي وبعض الدعم الشعبي والاهلي
ايضا كان مقدم هذه الدفعات التي قدمت هي
جزء يسير مما تحتاجه هذه العوائل المتضرره
براءه لكن كيف سيختلف الوضع عن السابق
لانه يعني في السابق قيل انه ان المشكله
كانت في وجود معبر واحد فقط مع تركيا الان
كيف سيتم التعامل مع هذه المشكله من اجل
ايصال المساعدات
كان يمكن للعميل
للامم المتحده ان يكون هناك طلب من
الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده للدخول
المساعدات ليس من معبر واحد وانما من عده
معابر كان يمكنهم ذلك ولكن الان
بعد ادراكهم
للاخطاء سوف يقومون بالعمل بالاسراع في
دخول المساعدات هذه الحدد التي كانت تقدم
منها ان المعبر مدمر ان بعض لا يمكنهم
الوصول ادركوا اخطائهم الان قالوا انهم
سوف يدركون الاخطاء بارسال المساعدات
عادله داخل سوريا نتمنى ان يكون هذا يترجم
على ارض الواقع ولا تكون عباره عن وعود
قدمت
لمؤسسه الدفاع المدني والمدنيين المتضررين
طيب الان ما هي الاحتياجات الطارئه التي
انتم بحاجه الي من اجل اكمال عملكم
ومساعده الناس
نحن
المعدات التي طلبناها اساسا منذ الساعه
الاولى لحدو سعر زلزال من معدات متطوره
بالاضافه ايضا لاليات ثقيله هذه المعدات
كان ستساعد في انقاذ الارواح والان ستساعد
في ازاله هذه الامطار نحن الان
بعد ان اوقفنا عمليات الانكسال عمليات
البحث والانقاذ وانتقلنا لمرحله الامتثال
نعمل الان على عمليات ايضا ازاله هذه
الالقاب هذه المعدات والاليات تساعد في
عمليات ازاله الانقاض بالاضافه انه
كمدنيين بحاجه الى ماوى عادل لانه اغلب
المدنيين الان متواجدين في بعض المحال
التجاريه ايضا من المساعدات التي وصلت من
الدول التي ذكرتها منذ قليل ايضا كان يوجد
بعض القيام الحاجه الاوليه هي وجود مراكز
ايواء تحوي هؤلاء المدنيين الموجودين في
العراء في المحال التجاريه حتى ايضا بعض
المطاعم التي اغلقت فتحه ابوابها
هذه الحادثه الاوليه
[موسيقى]
للاندرجه الحراره وصلت الى دون السطر ثلاث
درجات بالاضافه انه حاجه ماسه ايضا
المتضررين ذراء هذا الزلزال من المصابين
الذين وصلوا لعددهم الان الى 11 الف مصاب
هؤلاء يحتاجون الى رعايه طبيه يحتاجون الى
اسره تحريمهم كان يعاني ارتفاع طبي في
شمال غرب سوريا قبل حدوث زلزال من نقص في
المواد الطبيه بالاضافه ايضا نقص
الادويه بالاضافه هناك بعض المشاكل التي
اغلقت قبل حدوث الزلزال وكان يعمل
للتواقمها بشكل تطوعي الان نفس هذه
المشاكل ان تعمل تعمل
بواقمها الاستيعابه هؤلاء هذه من الحاجات
ماذا عن طيب هذا بالنسبه لموضوع الاستشفاء
والقطاع الاستشفائي ماذا ايضا عن المواد
الغذائيه الادويه يعني
الخدمات الاساسيه التي يحتاجها اي مواطن
كيف هو وضعها في تلك المناطق
مقارنه
نقارن الكارس الان الحاصل مع حجم
المساعدات فيحتاج المدنيين الى كثير
الكثير من المساعدات ان كان على المستوى
الغذائي المستوى الصحي الان خصوصا مع تفشي
الامراض امراض الكوليره التي كانت قبل
حدوث زلزال كان هنالك عده حالات مع من فرق
الدفاع المدني ايضا على نقل هذه الحالات
الى الاماكن المخصصه للاستثناء ولكن مع
هذا الزلزال وعدم وجود رعايه طبيه ايضا
للامراض
المتفشيه
والامراض التي حصلت الان يوجد حادم لها
ايضا
للقاع الطبي لمساعده القطاع الطبي ايضا
ايضا لمياه الشرب كما ذكرنا انه يوجد عده
حالات تفاصيل الامراض اشكرك احمد يازيجي
عضو مجلس اداره الدفاع المدني السوري
حدثتنا من ريفي ادلب
الضرر الهائل الذي خلفه زلزال تركيا يعود
لقدرته التدميريه الضخمه والمساحه التي
انتشر عليها والتي تشهد كثافه سكانيه
كبيره نتابع مزيدا من التفاصيل عن هذه
الارقام في العرض التالي
ليس سهلا تصور الضرر الهائل الذي احدثه
الزلزال فقد بلغت القدره التدميريه
للزلزالين ثلاثين اكوادريليون جول بما
يعادل نحو قنبله نوويه كتلك التي ضربت
هيروشيما من حيث القوه فحسب اذ ان الزلازل
لا تصدر اشعاعات نوويه جزء من الاضرار
الكبيره للزلزال هو المساحه الهائله التي
ضربها في عشر ولايات تركيه وتقدر باكثر من
مئه الف كيلو متر مربع بما يزيد عن مساحه
دوله كالنمسا
الكثافه السكانيه في هذه المنطقه عاليه
جدا ايضا فعدد السكان في تلك الولايات
العشر يزيد عن 13 مليون ونصف مليون نسمه
فضلا عن اثر الزلزال على دول اخرى كسوريا
ولبنان والاردن وفلسطين وقد بلغ عمق
الزلزال في تركيا سبعه كيلومترات تحت
الارض
الى تزحزح الارض ثلاثه امتار تقريبا كما
بلغ طول الفالق 500 كيلومتر الرقم كبير
اذا مقرن بزلزال السيشوان في الصين والذي
بلغ 300 كيلومتر او كاليفورنيا عام
1906 الذي بلغ نحو 400 كيلومتر
معلم من ولايه
اوريغاند المدير التنفيذي لمنظمه ريليف
انترناشونال مرحبا سيد
انتم في المنظمه لديكم فرق تعمل على الارض
حدثنا عن تقييمكم لحجم هذه الكارثه
والاوضاع
اوضاع النجينه منها
والمتضررين منها
شكرا على هذه الاستضافه لقد شاهدنا
المشاهد الفظيعه الوضع الميداني فظيع هذه
الكارثه منتشره واسعه النطاق ويؤلمنا ان
نرى حجم الدمار والخسائر والارواح في
المدن وفي القرى في كل هذه المناطق من
سوريا ومن تركيا فرقنا في الميدان تقوم
بمساعده من خلال العيادات
المتنقله التي تقدم خدمات الرعايه الصحيه
الاوليه الى المستشفيات وهناك مئات الناس
الذين هم بحاجه الى مساعده طبيه
هي ابرز التحديات التي تواجهونها في عملكم
الان على الارض وما ابرز المعوقات
ان التحديات والمعوقات الاساسيه
هي عباره عن مزيجا من اخراج الناس من تحت
الانقاض
وايضا باضافه الى ذلك البرد القارس الذي
يعرقل هذه العمليه وهناك ايضا خطر انهيار
المباني التي تشققت بفعل الزلزال والهزات
الارتداديه وبالاضافه الى ذلك يمكننا ان
نتحدث عن ضروره التاكد من ان معبر باب
الهوى يبقى مفتوحا لكي يتم ايصال
المساعدات الضروريه للاشخاص الذين هم
بحاجه
قوى المعارضه السوريه بدات تدعو الى
التحرك الفعال خارج نطاق الامم المتحده
ومجلس الامن لاغاثه السوريين وبدات تدعو
لفتح المزيد من المعابر لدخول المساعدات
الى الشمال السوري انتم كمنظمه معنيه
بالمساعده الانسانيه هل باستطاعتكم تلبيه
هذا الامر هل باستطاعتكم فعل ذلك
لا يمكنني ان اتحدث كثيرا عن الجانب
السياسي ولكن اود ان اقول نحن بحاجه الى
قدره على الوصول بشكل اكبر لكي نتمكن من
ايصال المساعدات الطبيه
والمساعدات الاخرى انا احس وادعو كل صانعي
القرار لكي ينظر بالقيم الانسانيه
المشتركه الضروريه لايصال المساعدات للناس
وما هي ابرز العوامل التي تعوق وصول هذه
المساعدات الى الشمال السوري
اعتقد انه يمكننا ان نتحدث عن سلسله من
الامور
ميدانيا الطرق صعبه هذه من بين التحديات
في طرفي الحدود بالاضافه الى القدره على
الوصول للمواد والمعدات
والاغراض المختلفه وطبعا هناك
الاعتبارات السياسيه وبالتالي المزيج من
هذه العوامل يصعب العمليه هل من شان فتح
المزيد من المعابر ان يحل المشكله ولو
جزئيا
لا نعم نعم هذا يساعد هذا يساعد اذا توسيع
معبر باب الهوى والمعابر القائمه هذا يكون
ممتاز بالفعل وطبعا الوقت يجب ان اتصرف
بوقت سريع طيب ماذا عن المرحله المقبله
الان بعد ان يعلن عن
اختتام عمليات الانقاذ كيف ستتطور سيتطور
موضوع المساعده على الارض في المرحله
المقبله في ضوء الاف ان لم يكن ملايين
المشردين الذين اصبحوا بلا ماوى وما الى
هنالك من مشاكل طالتهم
هذه هي المرحله التاليه هذه هي المرحله
المقبله نحن بحاجه الى المعدات والامدادات
التي تسمح بتامين الماوى للناس لكي يحتموا
من البرد نحن بحاجه الى الطعام والى
المعدات الطبيه كما ذكرت خصوصا في شمال
غرب سوريا لدينا عيادات متنقله ومستشفيات
متنقله نعمل من خلالها على تقديم الخدمات
الاوليه طبعا
النقطه الايجابيه هي انه كان لدينا بعض
المعدات قبل الزلزال كانت جاهزه ولكن سوف
تبقى قائمه او متاحه لاسابيع لذلك نحن
بحاجه الى معدات جديده شكرا لك
المدير التنفيذي لمنظمات اوريغن
قال الديوان الاميري ان امير دوله قطر
الشيخ تميم بن حمد ال ثاني غادر اسطنبول
بعد زياره بحث خلالها مع الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان في اسطنبول المستجدات
الاقليميه وعلاقات البلدين وهي اول زياره
لرئيس دوله الى تركيا عقب الزلزال اضاف
الديوان الاميري ان اميره قطر اعرب للرئيس
التركي عن تعازيه في ضحايا الزلزال وعن
تضامن قطر مع تركيا وشعبها واكد على
مواصله تقديم الدعم لتركيا لتجاوز تداعيات
الزلزال
وفي تغريده على تويتر اكد امير دوله قطر
الشيخ تميم بن حمد الثاني دعم بلاده
لتركيا وتضامنها معها كما اكد امير قطر
على مساهمه قطر في الجهود المبذوله
للتخفيف من كارثه الزلزال
قال وزير الخارجيه التركي مولود تشاويش
اوغلو ان تركيا ستطبع علاقتها مع اليونان
رغم وجود تباين في وجهات النظر بين
البلدين وشدد في مؤتمر صحفيا على ضروره
تطبيع العلاقات مع اليونان مشيرا الى ان
الجار الجيد يظهر في الايام العصيبه من
جهه اكد وزير الخارجيه اليوناني نيكوست
على وقوف اليونان مع تركيا في هذا الوضع
الصعب موضحا ان فريق الاغاثه اليوناني
انقذ 50 مواطنا تركيا
قال وزير العدل التركي بكر بوزداد يا ان
وزارته انشات مكاتب خاصه للتحقيق في
اتهامات بالغش في اعمال البناء الذي قد
يكون سببا انهيار المباني في الزلزال
انشئت مكاتب وخاصه للبحث يعني مسؤولين عن
انهيار المباني في الزلزال وستكون المكاتب
مسؤوله عن اجراء التحقيقات العدليه بشكل
قانوني وتحديد المهملين او المستغلين او
المستخدمين للمواد الرديئه حتى اليوم جرت
تحقيق ودراسه ملفات 134 مشتبها بهم وايقاف
ثلاثه منهم واعتقال سبعه اخرين ومنع سبعه
من السفر الى الخارج
وقد تعهدت السلطات التركيه باجراء تحقيق
مستفيد مع اي شخص يشتبه بمسؤوليته عن
انهيار المباني في زلزال الاثنين الماضي
وامرت باحتجاز 113 من المشتبه بهم على ذمه
التحقيق وقدرت السلطات عدد المباني التي
انهارت او لحقت بها اضرار جسيمه بنحو خمسه
وعشرين الفا مراسله الجزيره سلام خضر
رافقت فريقا من وزاره البيئه التركيه
اثناء جولته للتفتيش على مبان في ديار بكر
امام السيد امين مهمه معقده يقع على عاتقه
الكشف عن وضع المباني في المدينه
التوصيات التي سيخرج بها سيستند اليها في
اتخاذ قرار بهدم البنايات او اعلانها
صالحه للسكن
هذا التواء في الحديد في اساس المبنى
هنا مشكله التواء ايضا
وزاره البيئه التركيه نشرت فرقا ميدانيه
للتحقق من سلامه المباني وتحديد تلك التي
يجب هدمها
هناك سببان للضرر احدهما الزلزال والثاني
مشكله في سلامه البناء منذ انشائه الضرر
الاكبر ديار بكر هو ضرر بعيد الامد غير
بعيد عن عمليات الكشف في المباني بالمدينه
تعيش مئات العائلات في خيم مؤقته وفي وضع
يزيد الشتاء من قسوته اكثر من الف مبنى
اخلي من السكان
وهنا تتبلور ماساه الاخلاء
فجرا ولم نعد حتى الان اعمده المنزل
متضرره
اقفلنا منزلنا منذ اليوم الاول لا نعرف
وضعه حاليا
وكانت وزاره العدل التركيه اعلنت انها
انشات مكاتب للتحقيق في ادعاءات اهمال قد
يكون السبب وراء انهيار مباني وتضرر اخرى
سلام خضر الجزيره ديار بكر
من ولايه انديانا معنا اهان ارفانوجلو
رئيس قسم الهندسه المدنيه في جامعه بردو
مرحبا بك سيد عهان باعتقادك ما واجهت هذه
الاتهامات الموجهه لبعض المقاولين بان
ابنيتهم لم تتطابق مع المعايير وهو ما زاد
من حجم الدمار
ما وجاهت هذه الاتهامات من وجهه نظرك لبعض
المقاولين بان الابنيه التي قاموا
بانشائها لا تطابق المعايير المطلوبه وهو
مساهم في زياده الدمار من جراء الزلزال
بكل تاكيد تاكيد يجب ان يحاكم هؤلاء اذا
ما اثبت بالفعل انهم لم يلتزموا بالمعايير
ولكن يجب النظر بهذا الموضوع لا يمكنني ان
اعلق على هذا الموضوع حيث ان التفاصيل
ليست لدي وهي بين ايدي القضاء باعتقادك لو
انه جرى التقيد بمعايير البناء التي عاده
تتبع في مناطق معرضه لزلازل هل كانت فعلا
هذه الابنيه لتصمد ام ان حجم وقوه هذا
الزلزال
يعني لا يمكن التعامل معها بهذه الطريقه
يعني مجددا الامر يتوقف على
المناطق المختلفه هناك بعض المناطق التي
تتاثر بشكل كبير من حيث حركه الارض في
الزلزال وبالتالي يتوقف الامر على طريقه
البناء في المناطق المختلفه لكن كنا
نشاهد سيد ايهان التي عيناها يعني كنا
نشاهد مثلا ابنيه سويت بالارض بالكامل
وجنبها بناء ما زال موجوده
وذلك يعني باختلاف شارع ان لم يكن ان لم
تكن الابنيه بقربي بعضها البعض هل هناك
ايضا تفسير لذلك
مجددا لا يبرم ربما يجب ان
نقارن معايير البناء اما تكون افضل او
يكون المقاول المحظوظا اذا
الامر يتوقف على بنيه
المبنى وايضا حركه الارض تحت المبنى هذه
مشكله كبرى
ويمكن ان تسلط الضوء هذه المشكله على
افتراضاتنا بحسب او بالنسبه الى المخاطر
المقبوله على المستوى المجتمعي ولكن هناك
بعض المباني في بؤره الزلزال وكانت جيده
ومن حيث قدرتها على التحمل
وبقي الناس او يمكن الناس ان يعودوا اليها
نعم بالفعل هناك بعض المباني التي لا تزال
قائمه وفي بعض الاحيان الاخرى يجب التح
لمعرفه مدى سلامه المباني التي لا تزال
قائمه عاده سيد ايهان في مثل هذه المناطق
ما هي معايير البناء يعني ما هي معايير
البناء التي يجب اتباعها في مناطق مهدده
بالزلازل
هذا سؤال
للغايه نحن نستخلص العبر من الاخطاء ولكن
ايضا من النجاحات وبالتالي عندما يكون
لدينا بعض المدن التي تكون معرضه في تشيلي
في اليابان هذه المدن تاثرت بزلازل قويه
للغايه ولكن المباني ادت بشكل جيد جدا
فيها ليس تصميم هذا هذه المباني بالامر
الصعب هذا امر يرتبط بالثقافه اعتقد انه
يتعين علينا ان نحاكي طريقه البناء في هذه
الاماكن تشيلي واليابان هما من بين
الاماكن التي تم تشييد المباني فيها من
خلال استخدام
الاعمده اعمده الدعم وجدران الدعم بشكل
قوي
وبالرغم من حده قوه الزلازل هذه المباني
لم تتاثر شكرا لك ايهان ارفان اوغلو رئيس
قسم الهندسه المدنيه في جامعه بيردو من
ولايه انديانا
لجعل المباني المقاومه للزلازل يمكن
اللجوء لعده طرق هندسيه في الاحوال
العاديه تتعرض الابنيه عاده للقوه
العموديه بسبب الجاذبيه وتكون الخرسانه
العاديه قادره على تحمل تلك الضغوط لكن في
حاله الزلازل فهي تتعرض لقوه افقيه كذلك
ولا تستطيع مقاومتها الخرسانات العاديه
غير المسلحه اي تلك التي لم تضف اعمده
الحديد لها ولذلك تعتمد البلديات في
البلدان ذات النشاط الزلزالي الكبير الى
وضع شروط اضافيه على المقاولين قبل منحهم
رخص البناء لضمان ان تكون الابنيه المنفذه
من طرفهم قادره على مقاومه الزلازل لاسيما
فيما يتعلق بزياده كميه الحديد المضافه
للخرسانات لتحمل القوه المنبعثه من
الزلازل كما ان هناك اساليب اخرى لزياده
قوه البناء وقدرته على الصمود مثل استخدام
جدران القص وهي جدران خرسانيه مسلحه تمتد
من اساس البناء حتى اعلاه او يمكن اعتماد
تصميمات هيكليه من شانها نقل القوه
الافقيه الى الاساسات ومن ثم نقلها الى
الاعمده التي تتحمل القوات العموديه كما
يمكن استخدام اساسات مرنه تستطيع امتصاص
الهزات الارضيه والقوه القادمه من اسفل
البناء كل هذه الحلول يصممها المهندسون
بناء على حد ادنى لمقاومه الزلازل تحدده
البلديات عاده ويقوم المتعهدون بتنفيذه
لكن انهيار العديد من المباني في تركيا
خلال الزلزال الاخير رغم انها انشات وفق
المعايير التي اقرت بعيده زلزال ازميت عام
المتضمنه لشروط اكثر صرامه في معايير
البناء اثار العديد من التساؤلات بشان ما
اذا كان هناك التزام حقيقي بها ام ان
المقاولين ومتعهدي البناء التفوا على
المعايير ولجاوا لاستخدام كميات اقل من
الخرسانات المسلحه او مواد بناء رديئه
لتقليل التكاليف وزياده الارباح
استعرض فيما يلي وفق تسلسل زمني اقوى
الزلازل التي ضربت تركيا على مدى نصف
القرن الماضي نتابع
[موسيقى]
وفي التقرير التالي مزيد مزيد من الضوء
على الاسباب التي تجعل بعض مناطق العالم
اكثر عرضه للزلازل واي الزلازل كانت
الاكثر ضررا على البشر في القرن الماضي
محمود الزيبق يسحبنا في هذه الجوله
اين تحدث الزلازل في العالم ما اقوى
الزلازل التي حدثت في القرن الماضي وايها
الاكثر ضررا على البشر من حيث الخسائر
البشريه والماديه نجيب عن هذه الاسئله في
عرض يبسطها بشكل كبير هذه هي الزلازل التي
حصلت خلال نحو قرن من الزمان بحسب قوتها
بمجرد النظر الى الصوره نستطيع ملاحظه
معلومتين رئيسيتين تحدث الزلازل غالبا عند
اطراف القارات والتقائها ببعض المسطحات
المائيه لاحظوا مثلا التقاط التقاء المحيط
الهادئ بشرق اسيا او بغرب الامريكيتين
الملاحظه الثانيه هي اننا كلما دخلنا الى
وسط اليابسه في القارات قلت احتماليه
الزلازل كما نلاحظ هنا في اوراسيا وفي
افريقيا وايضا في وسط وشرق الامريكيتين
طبعا يرتبط هذا بمصطلح نسمعه كثيرا هذه
الايام هو الصفائح
التكتونيه وهي ببساطه قشره الارض العلويه
تم تسبع صفائح رئيسيه كما ترون من خلفي في
الخريطه اكبرها صفيحه المحيط الهادي من
الجانبين طبعا ثم امريكا الشماليه ثم
اوراسيا وكما لاحظنا تقع الزلازل على نقاط
التقاء هذه الصفائح الان نتابع اقوى
الزلازل في العالم الدوائر الحمراء التي
تشاهدونها هي لزلازل تجاوزت قوتها ثمانيه
درجات على مقياس ريختر بينما السوداء
الكبيره هي لزلازل تجاوزت تسع درجات وطبعا
اكبرها هو زلزال تشيلي عام 1960 والذي وصل
تقريبا الى 9.5 ثم زلزال الاسكا عام 64
9.2 زلزال سومطره في اندونيسيا
عام 2004 توهكو في اليابان وطبعا كل هذه
الزلازل تجاوزت تسعه درجات كما نلاحظ لكن
الزلزال الاكبر لا يعني انه الاكثر ضررا
اذ يرتبط هذا بالكثافه السكانيه في موقع
الزلزال زلزال تانك شان في الصين والذي
قدر عدد ضحاياه كما تشاهدون ب 300 الف كان
الاكثر ضررا بالبشر الثاني في الصين ايضا
زلزال هايوان برقم ضحايا مقارب ثم سمطره
بما يزيد علم 200 الف قتيل اعلى الزلازل
كلفه كما تلاحظون في هذه القائمه كانت في
اليابان في زلزالي توهكو وهانشين العظيم
وطبعا هذا الاختلاف لان الخسائر البشريه
تختلف عن الخسائر الماديه التي ترتبط عاده
بطبيعه البنيه التحتيه للمنطقه التي
يصيبها الزلزال
ينضم الينا من لندن السيد سانج ستريكان
ثاني المدير التنفيذي لمؤسسه شالتر بوكس
مرحبا بك سيد سانج اليوم لدينا ملايين
الاشخاص الذين اصبحوا بلا ماوى ما هي
الحلول الممكنه لهؤلاء على المدى القصير
والمتوسط
في البدايه هناك اشخاص ليس لديهم ماوى في
سوريا وتركيا بالنسبه الى البداء القصير
نحن بحاجه الى العمل على الحلول المؤقته
تتخصص بتقديم الخيام
والبطانيات المقاومه للمياه والامور
الاخرى لسد الحاجات الاوليه هذا على مستوى
اسابيع بالنسبه الى الاشخاص الذين فقدوا
المنازل في تركيا قد تكون الحلول اقرب
للعوده ولكننا نعرف ان الوضع في سوريا
اسوا لفتره ابعد وبالتالي لربما هم بحاجه
الى مساعدات على مستوى الطوارئ لمده سنه
او اكثر يعني ما الذي يمكن فعله تحديدا
بالنسبه
للسكان في سوريا خصوصا في ضوء
صعوبه اوضاع المساعده
التحدي الاكبر الذي نواجهه في تقديم
المساعدات هي القدره على ايصال المساعدات
الى الاشخاص الذين يتاثروا بهذا الزلزال
المعبر معبر باب الهوى فيه الكثير من
القوافل التي هي عالقه بالاضافه الى الطرق
التي
تعرقل حركه هذه القوافل نود على اصلاحا
للطرق وتسريع عمليه ايصال المساعدات عبر
باب الهوى والتوزيع
يعني كما ذكرت ان كانت المساعدات ان كانت
المساعدات الطارئه لا تصل الى الشمال
السوري ما الذي يمكن فعله على صعيد محاوله
تامين ماوى لمن فقدوا بيوتهم وهم بالالاف
ان لم يكن بالملايين في الشمال السوري
بشكل ناجع
هناك حلول متعدده اولا يمكن فتح معابر
متعدده ولكن الامم المتحده لم تتمكن سوى
من العمل عبر معبر باب الهوى اضافه الى
ذلك يجب العمل على الامدادات من المناطق
التي تسيطر عليها الحكومه الى المناطق
التي تسيطر عليها المعارضه ولكننا نعرف ان
هذا غير ممكن الان لذلك نركز على معبر باب
الهوى لدينا بعض المعدات والامدادات في
سوريا التي سوف نوزعها بافضل طريقه ممكنه
ولكن الحاجه مرتفعه للغايه والامداد لا
يزال ضئيلا ولكن
ماذا عن الحلول بالنسبه للماوى سيد سان
يعني انت تتحدث عن توزيع خيام ولكن هل هذا
حلول ناجعه ان طالت هذه الازمه حتى في
تركيا يتم الحديث عن اعاده الاعمار ليس
قبل سنه ماذا يفعل الناس بانتظار ذلك
الخيام التي توزعها شلتر بوكس مصممه
للاستخدام من تسعه الى 12 شهرا ونحن
نوزعها في سوريا اصلا واستعملها البعض
لسنوات اكثر من سنه في حقيقه الامر مع بعض
الصيانه نحن نثق بان الخيام يمكن ان
تستخدم لمده طويله ولكن المشكله هي ان
البرد لا يمكن ان تواجه هذه الخيام لذلك
طبعا يجب ان يكون هناك ماوى فيه دفء لهذه
العائلات شكرا لك من لندن سانج ستريكان
سان المدير التنفيذي لمؤسسه شلتر بوكس
حدثنا من لندن
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا الكرام منتصف الليل بتوقيت مكه
المكرمه تغطيتنا مستمره وهذا التذكير
بابرز العنب
شمال غرب سوريا مساعدات تتعثر بعد سبعه
ايام من الزلزال وسجال سياسي يطيل
الانتظار الامم المتحده تقر بخزلان
المتضررين ومفوضيه شؤون اللاجئين تقول
للجزيره ان معبر باب الهوى غير كاف
الاحتياجات وبين ريف حلب وشمال ادلب
كاميرا الجزيره ترصد يوميات فرق الدفاع
المدني وسط جهود انقاذ يقودها لفاد الوقت
ونقص المعدات
على الجانب الثاني من الحدود مشهد تركي
مماثل في الدمار ومختلف في تدفق المساعدات
عدد قتل الزلزال يقارب 30 الفا الامم
المتحده تحذر عدد الضحايا قد يتضاعف ورغم
تضاؤل الامل فرق الانقاذ تعثر على ناجين
بعد مضي اكثر من 150 ساعه على الزلزال
بعد انهيار وتضرر اكثر من 25 الف مبنى
جراء الزلزال تحقيقات تشتبه في مسؤوليه
بشريه في انهيار مبال جراء عدم التقيد
بالمعايير وسلطات التركيه تامر باعتقال
اكثر من مئه شخص والجزيره ترصد ابعاد
القضيه وملامح التحقيقات من ديار بكر
اذا مشاهدينا مع اقتراب الزلزال من اكمال
يومه السابع وصل عدد القتلى الى نحو
4,500 بالاضافه الى الاف الاصابات في شمال
سوريا قافله امميه تضم 10 شاحنات دخلت الى
شمال غرب سوريا عبر معبر باب الهوى مفوضيه
شؤون اللاجئين تقول للجزيره ان معبر باب
الهوى غير كاف لايصال الاحتياجات اما
الامم المتحده وفي تغريده لمارتين وكيل
الامين العام للامم المتحده لشؤون
الانسانيه فاقرت بخزلان المتضررين من
الزلزال في الشمال السوري
في مدينه حارم بادلب اختفت البيوت لتحل
محلها خيام هنا وهناك لكن الفرق بين عدد
البيوت التي تحولت الى ركام والعدد القليل
من الخيام التي نصبت شاسع جدا هنا تولد
احساس لدى الناس ان العالم تركهم يواجهون
مصيرهم وحدهم بعد الزلزال
اول قافله ارسلتها الامم المتحده عبر معبر
باب الهوى للمتضررين شمال غربي سوريا دخلت
بعد سته ايام من الزلزال والثانيه دخلت
بعد اليوم السابع قافلتان في سبعه ايام
لمواجهه كارثه مدمره سوريون رسموا العلم
الاممي مقلوبا وكتبوا عليه الامم المتحده
خذلتنا تلخص الصوره الشعور العامه في شمال
غربي سوريا يدعمها كلام وكيل الامين
العامل للامم المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه
مارتنغرفت الذي قال ان المجتمع الدولي خذل
من يعيشون في شمال غرب سوريا وانهم محقون
في شعورهم بان المجتمع الدولي تخلى عنهم
ودعا الى معالجه ما وصفه بالفشل في اسرع
وقت ممكن اما المبعوث الاوروبي الى سوريا
فقد دعا دمشق الى عدم تاسيس ملف المساعدات
الانسانيه ورفض اتهام الاتحاد الاوروبي
بالتقصير في تقديم ما يكفي من المساعدات
السوريين ماذا يقصد المبعوث الاوروبي
بتاسيس المساعدات هل هو اتهام مبطن للنظام
السوري بمنع وصول المساعدات الى مناطق
المعارضه رغم اعلانه السماح بذلك حتى الان
لم ترد اي معلومات تشير الى ان مساعدات
دوليه عبرت من مناطق نفوذ النظام الى
مناطق المعارضه
في دمشق تتحدث منظمه الصحه العالميه عن
انتظار موافقه من الطرف الاخر للعبور الى
مناطق شمال غربي سوريا لم يحصل السوريون
في هذه المناطق على المساعده لانقاذ من
يمكن انقاذهم في الايام التي تلت الزلزال
باعتراف الجميع الان المجتمع الدولي امام
اختبار اكبر فكارثه الزلزال تكشف عن وجوه
قبيحه عده تحتاج مساعدات على مدى شهور
وربما سنوات
كثيرون مثل محمد حاج حسين فقدوا بيوتهم
تقول الامم المتحده ان خمسه ملايين
وثلاثمائه الف سوري اصبحوا دون ماوى بسبب
الزلزال قضى في الزلزال من قضى وبقي عدد
مخيف من الجرحى والايتام والارامل
سيحتاجون مساعدات هائله بعيدا عن حسابات
السياسه
تواصلوا فرق الدفاع المدني السوري عمليات
انتشال الضحايا من تحت الانقاض في عده
بلدات برفي حلب وادلب شمال غربي سوريا
وتوجه فرق الانقاذ صعوبات عديده ابرزها
نقص المعدات واستنزاف قدرات الكوادر
العامله
ادارا العالم ظهره لهم فكانوا وحيدين في
وجه الكارثه
كارثه سبقتها مخاطر واهوال واجهها عبد
ورفاقه في الدفاع المدني شمال سوريا لكن
كارثه الزلزال اليوم انهكته ورفاقه وفاقت
قدراتهم
انا بوقت الزلزال كنت مناوي بعزاز الحمد
لله استجبنا
للناس المتضرره من الزلزال
والتحقنا بمدينه جنديرس لانه كان الضرر
فيها اكبر من هيك طلبوا مؤازرات الاغلب من
جميع الدفاع المدني
وكان في ضحايا تحت الانقاض وابنيه كتير
مدمره
والله عيالي ضليت يومين ما اعرف عنه شي
يومين ما اعرف عنه شيء بس انا مامن يعني
انه اهلي بحده
لا احد هنا يترقب خروج ناجم من تحت
الانقاض انتهت مرحله الصمت وفقد عبد
ورفاقه الامل في العثور على ناجين لكن
مهمه انتشار الضحايا لم تنته بعد
يواصلون العمل تاره بايديهم العاريه وتاره
اخرى بادوات خفيفه
وبما توفر من معدات ثقيله
تمر الساعات وينقضي اليوم ولا اثر للجثث
التي ابتلعها الركام
بعد اربعه ايام من العمل المتواصل يتوزع
فريق الدفاع المدني بعضهم يتابع العمل
واخرون يذهبون لاخذ قسط من الراحه
[موسيقى]
ان كانوا في دوامه المخاطر فهم عرضه لها
مرحبا بابا
في هذه السياره علوش تقضي عائلته يوميات
النزوح بعد ان تصدع منزلهم
يلا ربي يسلمك ويرضى عليك يا ابي هنا ينام
اطفاله لكنهم اليوم ظلوا حتى ساعه متاخره
من الليل يرقبون عوده والدهم يعلم الاب
انها لن تكون الا ساعه قليله سيبقى
الاطفال بعدها وحدهم في السياره ويبقى
الاب ورفاقه وحدهم في مواجهه الكارثه عمرو
حلب الجزيره ريفو
الينا من اعزاز في ريف حلب مراسل الجزيره
محمد الجزائري ومعنا من غازي عنتاب مراسل
الجزيره منتصر ابو نبوت مرحبا بكما سنبدا
معك محمد الجزائري في ريفيا حلب حدثنا كيف
تفاعل اليوم موضوع حديث
عن او اقراره بخذلان المجتمع الدولي
للسوريين
ومطالبه اجسام المعارضه السوريه بفتح
مزيدا من المعابر مع تركيا لادخال
المساعدات
نعمل تواصلنا مع كثير من الناس وتحدثنا
معهم اليوم عن موضوع المساعدات الدوليه
وعن التقصير والضعف وكما ذكر كلمه الخذلان
المجتمع السوري خلال هذه الازمه ولكن
الاهالي قالوا ان هذا هذه ليست المره
الاولى فماساتهم تتكرر ان كان في المعارك
وان كان في القصف وان كان في استخدام نظام
اسلحه
فتاكه في مناطق السكنيه وارتكابها مجازر
واكفي كل مره تكون
اصواتهم الى المجتمع الدولي دون اي تفاعل
دون اي
اي مساهمه في ايقاف ماساتهم في الحقيقه
هذه الماساه وهذا ما شهدناه اليوم من بين
الاهالي الذين تشردتهم شردتهم هذا الزلزال
والذين يفترشون الطرقات او
يجلسون في خيام على اطراف الطرقات يعيشون
اوضاع انسانيه صعبه خلال درجات الحراره
المنخفضه خلال نقص الامكانيات الاهالي
الذين شردتهم شردتهم
الزلزال هم ناجون من الزلزال نعم ولكنهم
باتوا الان هم ضحايا
نقص المساعدات ونقص الامكانيات ومعاناتهم
كبيره امام فوق بعد فقدانهم منازلهم
وممتلكاتهم بعض الاهالي الذين التقينا بهم
اليوم لا يملكون سوى بعض الملابس بعض
الملابس الذي يمتلكونها يلبسونها فقط لا
غير لم يستطيعوا اخراج اي شيء من منازعهم
قبل ان تهدم بعضها او بعضها المنازل هي
منازلهم قايله للسقوط او متصدعه لا يمكن
الاقتراب منها فقط تسقط في اي لحظه فهم لن
يغامروا بحياتهم في الوصول الى هذه
المنازل الى هذه الممتلكات حقيقه الواقع
صعب جدا امكانيات المنظمات جدا ضئيله
المنظمات تقدم لهم بما
تيسر لها ما تجده او ما تتمكن منه اما من
مواد غذائيه او بعض الوجبات الغذائيه بعض
الاغذيه بعض الخيام ولكن نحن نتحدث عن
ارقام كبيره جدا في هذا الصدد في هذه
الكارثه الكبيره بحسب مقاله منسقوه عفوا
وحده تنسيق الدعم ان الاعداد الاهالي او
عائلات التي باتت بلا ماوى قد يصل الى 11
الف عائله بالاضافه الى ان الشمال السوريه
يحتاج الى 13 الف خيمه
لاحتواء الذين فقدوا ماواهم فقدوا منازلهم
هذه الارقام كبيره وارقام ضخمه بالمقارنه
مع امكانيات المنظمات المحليه
والمنظمات الدوليه
والمجتمع الدولي او الامم المتحده لم تقدم
الا المساعدات الضائله بحسب ما قاله
مسؤول المنظمات ان المساعدات التي دخلت من
معبر لا تكاد تكفي كم كبير كم قليل من
الاهالي المتضررين وهذا رقم كبير امام
امكانيات ضعيفه فقد تشهد الشمال السوري
ازدياد في مخيمات العشوائيه ازدياد في
حاله الفقر ازدياد في حاله العوز
والمعاناه بشكل كبير
حلب مراسلنا محمد
الجزائري تحديدا من اعزاز وقبل ان انتقل
الى منتصر ابو نبوته في غازي عنتاب اعلن
مرصد الزلازل التركي قبل قليل عن تسجيل
ثلاث هزات ارتداديه تتراوح قوتها بين 4.1
واربعه فاصل سبعه على مقياس ريختر في
مدينه كهرمان مرعش ما ادى الى ايقاف مؤقت
لاعمال الانقاذ قرب مباني متداعيه في حين
اعلنت هيئه المسح الجيولوجي الامريكيه
تسجيل هزه ارضيه تبلغ شدتها 4.9 درجه على
مقياس ريختر في ولايه ملاطيا التركيه
الى اثنتي عشره هز ارتداديه اخرى في تركيا
وشمال غربي سوريا في الساعات القليله
الماضيه
نعود الى منتصر ابو نبوت مراسلنا في غازي
عنتاب منتصر كنا نشاهد واياك قبل قليل
المخيم الذي اصبح في داخل المدينه والخيم
التي بات يسكنها الذين فقدوا منازلهم كيف
يبدو المشهد على الارض وكيف تتحول عمليات
الاغاثه في هذه المرحله
يعني انسي في الحقيقه
المخيمات هي يعني تكون في جميع الحدائق
تقريبا هي لا تكون بمعنى المخيمات الكامله
هناك اشخاص ياتون ببعض
المواد الاساسيه التي متوفر لديها مثل ما
يعرف في الشوادر ويقومون بنصبها حتى في
الحدائق الصغيره القريبه من منازلهم لانهم
لا يريدون ان عوده الى هذه المنازل لكنهم
يسكنون ايضا بالقرب منازلهم اذا كان هنالك
حديقه قريبه منهم عمليات الاغاثه طبعا
مستمره لكن هذا الامر ليس سهلا في ظل يعني
الوقت في ظل وقت ضيق عاشته مدينه غازي
عنتاب منذ وقوع الزلزال وحتى الان وخصوصا
ان الجهود كانت مركزه في عمليات الانقاذ
اليوم نحن امام ساعات حاسمه متعلقه في
عمليه الانقاذ التي مستمره بالمناسبه حتى
هذه اللحظه في مدينه غازي عنتاب وفي مدينه
نورداغ وفي مدينه الاصلاحيه هذه هاتين
المدينتين تابعات الاداريه لولايه غازي
عنت نحن الان نتحدث عن ماساه كبيره
بالنسبه
للكثير من العوائل هذه احد الحدائق
الصغيره التي يتواجد فيها عدد من العوائل
التي تسكن بالقرب من هنا هنا يوجد مسجد
هذا المسجد تحول الى مركز للايواء هذا
المسجد هنا تحول لمركز وتتواجد داخله بعض
العائلات هنا كما نشاهد بعض الاشخاص
يقومون بايقاد النيران للحصول على بعض
الدفع في ظل درجات يعني الحراره المتدنيه
وهذا طبعا هم لانهم قريبين من هذا المسجد
كما نشاهدون في هذه في هذه الصوره ايضا
بالجانب الاخر هنا
يمكننا ان نشاهد عبر الكاميرا في هذا
الجانب هذه مثلا احد المقاعد المخصصه
للحديقه هذه كان كان مقعدا مخصوصا الحديقه
قام احد الاشخاص بوضع هذه الستاره وهي
يعني من نوع محدد من الاقمشه لمنع البرد
وقام باشعال في الداخل يقوم بالجلوس فيها
والعيش فيها واشعال يعني النيران داخلها
ايضا هنالك اشخاص استغلوا هذه المقاعد كما
نشاهد هنا ايضا مثل هذه المقاعد وقاموا
ببناء هذه مثل هذه الشهداء طبعا هذه فيها
مخاطر كبيره لانها ليس ضد الحرائق وقد
يعني ينطوي عليها بعض المخاطر بالنسبه
للاهالي الذين يسكنون فيها ايضا شاهدنا
بعض الاشخاص قد جلبوا معهم حيواناتهم
الاليفه مثل الكلاب والقطط لانهم ايضا لا
يريدون ان يتركوهم تحت الانقاذ ويعني في
منازلهم تخوف من هذا الامر هنا شاهدنا
شخصا قبل قليل وتحدثنا معه هو لديه خيمه
للتقسيم العادي المعروف لكنه استخدمها في
قضيه يعني العيش يعني سنحاول التحدث
السلام عليكم
منزلك تضرر خلال هذه الضربه الزلزال طبعا
منزلي ومنازل جميع الموجودين بالحديقه
نسبه الضرر شي 90 او 95% انا استخدمت هاي
الخيمه لانه بصراحه ما في خيم خيمه الافاد
يعني العدد قليل ومعظم اللاجئين اللي
موجودين حاليا بالحديقه يعني اللي اسعفوا
الحظ عنده تشادر قديم استخدمه انا استعرض
هاي الخيمه من عند اصدقائي بس هي شكليا هي
ماتقي لا برد ولا ايش يعني نستخدم النار
حاليا حطب وضع كثير سيء بالنسبه للموجودين
للحديقه وبالنسبه نقدر نصور القيمه من جوا
كيف طبعا
سنحاول يعني هذه القيمه من الداخل يجلس هو
وصديقه بداخلها
كما نشاهد انسي وهم ايضا يستخدمون هذا
بعض الجيلاتين الذي يضعوه في محيط هذه
المقاعد وايضا هنا
يقومون باشعال النيران في محاوله للحصول
على بعض الدفء كما ذكر طبعا هذا الامر
لاننا نتحدث عن اعداد كبيره من الناس نزلت
الى الشوارع الاعداد الرسميه للقيام هي
19,000 خيمه تحدثت عنها
السلطات الرسميه وايضا هناك 5000 خيمه
منها في مدينه الاصلاحيه واحده في ملعب
الاصلاحيه الذي تحول الى مخيم لذلك لا
يوجد عدد كبير يعني من الخيام او عدد كافي
وكما تحدث الرئيس التركي انه كان هناك ضعف
في الاستجابه في البدايه وان هذا الامر
سيتم تداركه وولديه غازي عنتاب تحدثت عن
هذا الامر وقالت ان الامر سينتقل الان الى
الاحترافيه في التعاطي مع هذا الامر بعد
امتصاص الصدمه الاولى التي
تعرضت لها كل المدن التركيه وحتى يعني
شمال سوريا طبعا هنا نحن نتحدث عن كما
ذكرت اوضاع صعبه ونتحدث ايضا عن اغاثه
الاهالي هم هم بحاجه اليها وايضا هنالك
امر مهم اننا نتحدث عن اشخاص يسكنون في
هذه القيامه وفي هذه قد لا يكون نزلهم
تضررت بشكل كبير قد تكون صالحه للسكن لكن
الخوف من الزلازل والهزات الارتزاديه التي
لم تتوقف المناسبه وكما ذكرتي قبل قليل في
النشره هذا الخوف من هذا الامر يدفع
الاهالي للبقاء في الحدائق العامه وفي
الشوارع هنالك حدائق كبيره تحولت الى
مخيمات فعليا وهنالك حدائق صغيره بالقرب
من منازل او بالقرب من الابنيه التي
يسكنون فيها يجلس فيها الهدف من الوجود
هنا هو ان هذه الابنيه في حال سقطت او
بسبب بفعل الزلزال لا سمح الله طبعا فانهم
يكونون بعيدين عن هذه
الركام او هذا الردم ويكون نوعا ما بالرغم
من هنا يوجد عمدان ويوجد بعض اشرطه
الكهرباء واشجار وهذه ايضا قد تتضرر لانها
شاهدنا اشجار في بعض الحدائق كانت وقعت
على الارض سقطت ارضا وايضا جاهدنا اشجار
وعمدان كلها سقطت ارضا لفعل الزلزال نعم
يعني الزلزال يطال
بالضرر مناحي كثيره من حياه الناس اشكرك
على هذه
الاطلاله منتصر ابو نبوت مراسلنا من غازي
عنتاب
مرور اسبوع كامل على الزلزال لم يمنع من
العثور على ناجين بعد كل هذه الايام وبعد
سبعه ايام تمكنت فرق الانقاذ في مدينه
هاتاي المنكوبه من انقاذ امراه مسنه بعد
152 ساعه
وبعد 140 ساعه انتشلت فرق الانقاذ الطفل
حمزه ذات سبعه اشهر
وفي هاتاي كذلك ام وطفلها خرج حيين من تحت
الانقاض بعد سبعه ايام على الزلزال
[موسيقى]
في غضون ذلك استطلع فريق من الاطباء
المتطوعين في الهلال الاحمر القطري
الاوضاع الميدانيه في مناطق شماليه غربي
سوريا بعد عبوره من معبر باب الهوى
الحدودي مع تركيا اضاف المراسل ان الفريق
مكون من 12 طبيبا من مختلف التخصصات لدعم
القطاع الطبي في المناطق المنكوبه جراء
الزلزال
هدفنا ووصلنا هنا الى باب الهوى في الجانب
السوري معنى فريق طبي متواجد معنا من عدد
من الاطباء
متخصصين في عدد من التخصصات المهمه حقيقه
تخصصات في الجراحه العامه
بتخصص بالاطفال ايضا للنساء ايضا جراحات
التجميليه ايضا عندنا طبيب نفسي ايضا
موجود معنا فكل هذه التخصصات صراحه جزاهم
الله خير تبرعوا ضمن فريق الهلال انه
ياتوا يقدموا هذا الدعم الصحي
للمحتاجين داخل الاراضي معنا معدات تم
شحنها من دوله قطر سيتم ادخالها ان شاء
الله الى داخل السوري فان شاء الله باذن
الله يعني او ايضا عندنا فرق اخرى ايضا
راح تاتي تباعا
مع تراجع الامال بالعثور على ناجين يتحول
عمل الخوذ البيضاء في شمال شرق سوريا الى
انتشار الجثث ورفع الانقاض وتلك مهمه
تتعقد اكثر في ضوء غياب اي مساعدات فعليه
من الخارج واعتماد فرق الانقاذ على
امكاناتها المحدوده والمستنزفه بعد اسبوع
من العمل الشاق
كثير من الموتى قليل من الاحياء تلك هي
المعادله الان في المناطق المنكوبه بعد
مضي اسبوع على كارثه الزلزال في شمال غربي
سوريا تدخل مهمه فرق الانقاذ مرحله
الاحباط والياس فهي الان تكاد تنحصر في
انتشال الجثث ورفع الانقاض وحده تنسيق
الدعم التي تتولى استلام المساعدات
وتوزيعها في تلك المناطق اكدت ان عدد
القتلى تخطى اربعه الاف بينما يقترب عدد
الجرح والمصابين من ثمانيه الاف وهي حصيله
غير نهائيه حيثما يزال مئات الاشخاص
عالقين تحت الانقاض فيما لا يقل عن 90
مبنى منهارا
عوامل كثيره جعلت الكارثه هناك بهذا السوء
منها عدم وصول اي فرق اغاثه خارجيه او
معدات حفر في الوقت المناسب ولا حتى بعد
فوات الاوان كما ان الزلزال ضرب اكثر من
100 موقع يضم كل منها مباني ومنازل بكثافه
سكانيه متفاوته فضلا عن ان المنطقه التي
يتكدس فيها مئات الاف النازحين الفارينه
من هجمات النظام السوري كانت اصلا في ظروف
سيئه قبل الزلزال
قائمه الاحتياجات طويله وتتصدرها طلبات
عاجله لاكثر من مئه فرقه انقاذ لدعم فرق
الدفاع المدني المحلي التي يعمل فيها
حاليا اقل من الف متطوع كما تشمل
الاحتياجات العاجله اكثر من 400 اليه
مختلفه المهام والوظائف من شاحنات لنقل
الركام واليات للحفر والنبش وجرافات
واليات اخرى اما متطلبات السكان بمن فيهم
الناجون والمصابون والذين باتوا بلا ماوى
فتبدو اكثر استعجالا وفق نداء وحده تنسيق
الدعم يحتاجون اكثر من 100 الف وجبه طعام
يوميا ونحو 160 الف قطعه من الاغطيه
والمفارش فضلا عن اكثر من سته ملايين لتر
من وقود التدفئه في مناخ شتوي بالغ القسوه
من ريفي حلب معنا عاطف نعنوع مديره فريقي
ملهم التطوعي مرحبا بك سيد عاطف ما هي اهم
المستلزمات الان الطارئه التي يحتاج اليها
الناجون
مساء الخير الى كل الساده المشاهدين
بالرحمه للشهداء الزلزال والشفاء العاشر
للجرحى والله يصبر كل من فقد
كل شيء يعني الاجابه لسؤالك الاشخاص اللي
زلزالنا بحاجه كل شيء من الملابس للبيت
الماوى
الشغله الصحيه
اي كل شي مي
غذاء دواء كل شيء حرفيا نحن عم نحكي عن
كارثه
وقعت
ببلد او بمدن هي ضمن كارثه من اكثر من عشر
سنين
اشخاص
عاشوا هالسنتين من دون نزوح او او اذن
عاشوا من دون نزوح ففقدت القيام لعدم
الحاجه لها
سواء التجار او المنظمات
زلزال
دمر اكثر منا عشره الاف
بيت واكثر من عشرين الف بيت متضرر طلعوا
من الناس 30 الف عائله
خيم ما في مراكز ايواء ما في ناس اصلا في
كثافه سكانيه عاليه بهالمنطقه نتيجه تهجير
من قبل مدن اللي كان فيها 5000 ولا فيها
خمسين الف ماذا يفعل الناس
هذا الوضع يعني كيف يتعاملون مع هذا
الموضوع لا سيما موضوع
بالنسبه لموضوع الايواء الخامس صارت حلم
فبالتالي الناس اتجهت من مدن المدمره
لمخيمات عند اقربائهم اللي عايش بخيمه اذا
كانت عايشه فيها عيله هلا حاليا عايشه
فيها ثلاث عائلات او عيلتين ناس فوق بعضها
حرفيا درجه الحراره حاليا شوي شفتها اثنين
او اربع درجات مئويه عم توصل باخر الليله
الاربعه الى الصفر او ناقص اربعه كمان
درجه مئويه
الامم المتحده اعتزرت اليوم عن
التاخر بالاستجابه وكانه كل ثلاث دقائق او
كل اسبوعين بيصير زلزال فهالمره تاخرنا
غريبه جدا طريقه التعاطي المجتمع الدولي
مع قضيتنا او مع كوارثنا كانه صارت سوريا
اوكي ما في مشكله خلينا
اعترفت به اليوم الامم المتحده
ما كانت كلفته باعتقادك على السوريين مما
عينته على الارض ارواح ارواح والله لو
متاخرين بسرعه الاغاثه ما اختلفنا لو
متاخرين باي شيء ثاني ما اختلفنا ارواح
ارواح
في فتره ذهبيه وفتره فضيه ما بعرف شو
بسموهن اول يوم بكون نسبه انه نلاقي ناس
عايشه تحت الانقاذ يعني بكون اكبر كل
تاخير يوم واحد بيجوا بعد انتهاء
كل الفترات وانتهاء مرحله البحث والانقاص
بيعتزلوا ما بدخلوه يعني ما بيعملوا شي بس
بعتذروا
كانه
بصير بشكل اسبوعي لا لا ابدا الموضوع ما
في حاجه اعتذار اصلا ليش
تذكرنا او تعترفنا انك غلطت خلنا ننسى
الموضوع ذكرنا فيه غريبه جدا تعاطي
الاشخاص والله اليوم انا موجود حاليا
موجود حاليا بخيمه من فوق الركام اسمحي لي
بس حرك الكاميرا معلش موجود بخيمه من فوق
الركام واضح يمكن المنظر
بنفكر
انا حاليا موجود بريف ادلب انتقلت ريف
ادلب منطقه حارم احد المناطق اللي اضطرت
من الزلزال نصبنا خيمه بث مباشر وحاليا
على البث المباشر قدام الاف الناس
بهالمقابله كرمال فقط نطلق صندوق اسمه
اعاده اعمار مناطق المتضرره جمعنا لحد
اللحظه لحد اللحظه
4.7 مليون دولار بس نوجه رساله للعالم انه
اللي بدي عمرها السوريين من المواطنين
تحت الانقاذ ما في عمره اصلا
نعنوع ما هي اكثر المناطق تضررا
وكيف يعني بظلم الوضع الذي شرحته لنا
والحاجه الى كل شيء كما ذكرت كيف يتم
التعامل مع كل ذلك في في ظل هذا الشح
اكثر المناطق تضرا حين منطقه منطقه اخر
منطقه بريف حلب
منطقه حدوديه معاريف ادلب
هاي المنطقه الاكثر ضررا اكثر من 80 مبنى
على الارض منتقل بعض بعد الريف ادلب منطقه
سلقين ومنطقه حارم ومنطقه ترمانين والارب
منطقه في منطقه بين سلقين هون بعيد عننا
واحد كيلو متر بين سلقين وحارم اسمه بسنيا
150 بيت مجمع سكني حديث للاسف
انهار بالكامل لم يخرج منه احد الا يمكن
هذا المبدا اللي ورايا حاليا
يوم القيامه الناس
ما طلعت من الصدمه انه انه ناسها واهلها
تحت الانقاض الا دخلت بصدمه ثانيه يلعنها
بالماوى العلاقه بي بانه وين تروح طيب
الان ما هي الحلول ما هي الحلول وفقه وجهه
نظرك سيد عاطف ووفقه معينتك على الارض من
اجل التغلب على هذا الوضع خصوصا في ظل
وجود معبر واحد فقط بين تركيا
واراضي الشمال الغرب السوري
الحل
وبكل شفافيه
البدء بانشاء مراكز ايواء كريمه
للناس اللي كانت قاعده البيوت وتهدمت او
تضرت او طلعت منها ثم ادخال المساعدات
الغذائيه
والمساعدات الاساسيه وليس ادخال المساعدات
الاغراسيه او الغذائيه او الاساسيه من
فرشات وحراماتهم بطانيات تدخل من المعابر
وين تروح الناس منتشرين
بيرجعوا ممكن يوزعوا على المخيمات موجوده
اصلا وين بيروحوا الناس اكيد بده يروحوا
عند اقرباء فبالتالي الناس مو موجوده
بمراكز ايواء لحتى نقول
للشاحنات روحي ساعديهم الشاحنه بتفوت ما
بتعرف حرفيا وين تروح لانه ما تم تاسيس
مراكز ايواء المخيمات يعني او الخيام لازم
توصل الكرفانات اي شيء فيما بعد ذلك فيما
بعد ذلك بعد مرحله الايواء وتقديم الخدمات
اللازمه الهن
بس لازم نركز على اول شغله هي الايواء
جمال باماكن معينه لنقول هدول المضري
زلزال
بعدها نتلقى الصدمه فمنروح لمرحله البناء
اللي لازم تتم واللي بده يرفضه طبعا
المجتمع الدولي اللي هو اصلا ما ساعد
الضحايا نحن تولينا المهمه من خلال حمله
فريق متطوعي
متطوعي كرمال نعوض الناس نحن بدنا نعوض من
اليوم بلشنا وراح نبلش بكره بالاعمار
كرمال نساعد
انشاء انشاء مراكز الايواء التي تحدثت
عنها من الذي يجب ان يقوم بذلك
لما نحكي عن مراكز ايواء لناس بالالاف لا
بد انه المنظمات المعنيه بالموضوع الدوليه
التي تدعم الشمال السوري من عشر سنوات ان
يكون في عندها رده فعل استثنائيه
لانه الموضوع مو موضوع ولا قصف بنايه ولا
بنايتين موضوع
انهيار كامل
للمبانية فبالتالي لا بد من توجيه الدعم
اللي موجود والاموال اللي موجوده تحويلها
من الشغلات الغير ضروريه حاليا
لشيء ضروري استثنائي رجال عاطف
التطوعي حدثتنا من ريفي ادلب شكرا لك
قال الديوان الاميري ان امير دوله قطر
الشيخ تميم بن حمد اللسان غادر اسطنبول
بعد زياره بحث خلالها مع الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان في اسطنبول المستجدات
الاقليميه وعلاقات البلدين وهي اول زياره
لرئيس دوله الى تركيا عقب الزلزال اضاف
الديوان الاميري ان امير قطر اعرب للرئيس
التركي عن تعازيه في ضحايا زلزال وعن
تضامن قطر مع تركيا وشعبها واكد على
مواصله تقديم الدعم لتركيا لتجاوز تداعيات
الزلزال
وفي تغريده على تويتر اكد امير دوله قطر
الشيخ تميم بن حمد ال ساني دعم بلاده
تركيا
وتضامنها معها كما اكد امير قطر على
مساهمه قطر في الجهود المبذوله للتخفيف من
كارثه الزلزال
معنا من اسطنبول حسن عينجي المسؤول في
هيئه الاغاثه الانسانيه التركيه مرحبا بك
سيد حسن على ماذا ستركز
اعمالكم على الارض خلال المرحله المقبله
اولا اشكركم للاستضافه نحن كهيئه الانسان
اي شاشه التركيه من بدايه الاول الساعات
من الزلزال مباشره تدخلنا في الامر خاصه
بفرقنا الانقاذ وبعد ذلك ثم مباشره تدخلنا
بالفريق الاغاثه
لمتضررين الزلزال سواء في تركيا وسواء في
سوريا نحن طبعا بعد هذه الفتره نتركز في
موضوع خاصه الايواء لان كما تعرفون هناك
في المنطقه سواء في تركيا او سوريا هناك
الشتاء فارس جدا في قد تجد في بعض الاماكن
حتى درجه الحراره قد يصل تحت الصفر الى
ثمانيه والى عشره درجات والناس طبعا
يحتاجون بشكل كبير الى ايواء طبعا لا
نستطيع ان نقول انه لا
هناك اصلا حكومه حكومه التركيه تقوم
بدورها
نحن كاهيل هيئه
المؤسسه اهليه في تركيا نقدم المساعدات
المتضررين الزلزال وان شاء الله نحن بدانا
ان نعمل الخيم خاصه في المناطق الذين
تضرروا بشكل كبير سواء في انطاكيا او غازي
عنتاب او كهرباء
لتامين الايواء ولو يكون مؤقتا لان خاصه
في هذه المناطق الناس يعيشون في تحت برد
القاسي
لنقدم لهم هذه المساعدات الايواء ليعيشوا
فيها وطبعا
لابد ان نقول عنده هناك لدينا بعض
المشاركات مع بعض المؤسسات الخليجيه
للايواء في داخل السوريه هناك عدد من
المخيمات موجوده وحتى هناك عدد من
المخيمات تحت الانشاء نحن ان شاء الله
نسرع العمل
لتنفيذ هذه المخيمات خاصه في داخل تركيا
ولدينا هناك مشروب كبير المشروع
الهاويات او البيوت المتنقله لتقديم
الايواء للمتضررين الزلزال في داخل تركيا
كمان ولكن سيد حسن عندما تتحدث عن الخيام
يعني الى متى يمكن للذين فقدوا منازلهم ان
يعيشوا في هذه الخيام خصوصا ان الضرر كبير
والحلول او او اعاده الاعمار قد تستغرق
وقتا طويلا جدا
نعم طبعا المشروع الايواء الاول او المؤقت
الخيم وقد يكون لمده يعني بدات اشهر بعد
ذلك طبعا نحن اسنان قمنا
لاتفاقيات مع بعض الشركات
للحاويات او البيوت المتنقله لان بعد ذلك
اصلا الحكومه ومؤسسات اهليه تقوم بادل
المشاري الثابته لمتضررين الزلزال هو يكون
يعني فتره كما اخبرتكم بدعه اشهر فقط
القيم
ليكون حل السريع لان تستطيع ان كما تعرفون
يعني
التنفيذ المشاري الخيم يكون بسرعه لان نحن
نحتاج التدخل السريع في مشروع الايواء
لسبب ذلك ندخل هذا الموضوع ولكن بعد ذلك
نحن كمؤسسه اهليه اياها مثالا عندنا بعض
الافكار وبعض المشاريع
نقدم للمتضررين الزلزال هو يكون ان شاء
الله يكون
مشاري الايواء يكون لمده سنه او سنتين الى
حد ما يرجعون الى بيوتهم الاصليه اشكرك
حسن عنجي المسؤول في هيئه الاغاثه
الانسانيه التركيه ضيفنا من اسطنبول
تعاهدت السلطات التركيه باجراء تحقيق
مستفيد مع اي شخص يشتبه بمسؤوليته عن
انهيار المباني في زلزال الاثنين الماضي
وقد امرت باحتجاز 113 من المشتبه بهم على
ذمه التحقيق وقد قدرت السلطات عدد المباني
التي انهارت او لحقت بها اضرار جسيمه بنحو
25 الفا
بفعل الزلزال ام الانسان من بيت احلام الى
ما يشبه فتات البسكويت بطعم الموت من
المسؤول عن انهيار مباني حديثه في تركيا
بعضها لم يسكنها اصحابها سوى لشهور يتحمل
هذا المقاول ومئات من امثاله وزر الحصيله
الكارثيه لهزه ارضيه ارتدادتها غير
الطبيعيه ستستمر وقتا طويلا وثقت كاميرات
المراقبه في مطار اسطنبول لحظه اعتقاله
كان يحاول الهرب الى الجبل الاسود وبحوزته
مبلغ مالي هو مقاول مجمع سكني فخم فيها
تاي كان يسميه الجنه سكانه عاشوا جحيمًا
بعد انهياره منهم من فارق الحياه ومنهم من
وجد نفسه في العراء لا اثر لدعايه المجمع
على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي والمواقع مثل
اغلب الاعلانات التي كانت تتباهى باستخدام
افضل انواع مواد البناء
واحترامي المعايير المضاده للزلازل لا
وجود لها حذفت مع سقوط تلك المباني بمن
فيها كاوراق اللعب حسب وزاره البيئه
التركيه ناهز عدد المباني التي انهارت او
تضررت بشده بسبب الزلزال خمسه وعشرين الفا
حجم الدمار الهائل زاد من غضب الاتراك
الذين يطالبون بملاحقتي ومحاسبتي كل مسؤول
عن ذلك باشرت وزاره العدل العمليه انشات
مكاتب خاصه ضمن مكاتب المدعين العامين في
المحافظات العشر المنكوبه ذكر وزير العدل
التركي تفاصيل في اعلانه عن الخطوه
فتكون المكاتب مسؤوله عن اجراء التحقيقات
العدليه بشكل قانوني وتحديد المهملين او
المستغلين او المستخدمين للمواد الرديئه
حتى اليوم جرت تحقيق ودراسه ملفات 134
مشتبها بهم وايقاف ثلاثه منهم واعتقال
سبعه اخرين ومنع سبعه من السفر الى الخارج
ب
اعتراف طن واداره الطوارئ في لندن كانت
قوه الزلزال عنيفه ولكنها ليست كافيه
بالضروره لهدم مباني شيدت حديثا اين يكمن
الصدع الذي هوى بكل هذا العمران خلال
الثواني على الورق شددت انقره معايير
البناء في اعقاب الكوارث الطبيعيه السابقه
يعود اخر تحديث لها الى عام 2018
ضمن تلك الشروط استخدام خرسانه عاليه
الجوده معززه بقضبان ثلاثيه لمقاومه
الزلازل ويجب ايضا توزيع الاعمده والحواجز
لامتصاص تاثير الزلازل بشكل فعال على
الارض تطبيق تلك القوانين يبقى ضعيفا ومن
اسباب هذه المشاهد المرعبه منها تاي الى
ديار بكر وكرمان مراش وملاطيا الغش في
مواد البناء يتحدث المهندسون عن النوعيه
الرديئه للاسمنت المستخدم يمزج مع من
الماء والحصى وقليل جدا من الاسمنت هناك
ايضا نوعيه قضبان الحديد التي قد تكون
رقيقه جدا ولا يمكنها دعم الاعمده تكثر
الاسباب ومصيبت هؤلاء واحده منهم من يضطر
لمشاهده عشرات الجثث بحثا عن قريب
الله اكبر بعض الجثث دفنت بلا شاهد يذكر
اسماء اصحابها مرت ايام ولم يتعرف احد
عليها فوجب اكرام الموتى تمت التصدع كبير
في سوق البناء بتركيا ترميمه ضروره ملحه
لتفادي مقاس اخرى
معنى من لندن جيمز دينسلو رئيسه قسم
المناصره بمنظمه انقذوا الاطفال سيد جيمس
مرحبا بك هل لديكم
احصاءات معينه حول اعداد الاطفال الذين
تاثروا بهذه الكارثه سواء في تركيا او في
سوريا
لسوق الحظ الاحصائيات او اي معلومات او
بيانات من الصعوبه مكان ان نصل اليها بعد
اقل من اسبوع على حدوث هذه الكارثه اذا ما
احتسبنا الفئه العمريه لسكان هذه المنطقه
نحن نتحدث عن حوالي سبعه ملايين طفل او
اكثر هذه التقديرات ولكن في اللحظه
الراهنه ليس لدينا اي بيانات دقيقه نحن في
مرحله البحث والانقاذ وهناك انقاذ للناس
من تحت الانقاذ وبالتالي هناك صعوبه في
توثيق هذه الامور وفهم الديناميات
المختلفه لهذه الكارثه ما في صداره
الازمات التي قد يعاني منها الاطفال في
هذه
الكارثه هي مساله اليتم كيف يتم التعامل
مع هذه الازمه الكبيره
نعم لقد شاهدنا قصصا وصورا فظيعه لاطفال
خسروا تقريبا كل افراد عائلتهم لدينا فرق
في البلدين وهناك اطفال يصلون الى الماوي
التي تقدم لهم
الطعام الساخن ولكنهم لوحدهم اذا هناك
مهمه اساسيه تقضي بحمايه هؤلاء بالاضافه
الى الخيام والطعام والمعدات الطبيه يجب
حمايه الاطفال من اتم الاتجار بهم ومن
الامور الاخرى الخطره على حياتهم وطبعا
يجب تامين مستقبل افضل بالنسبه الى هؤلاء
يجب ان نعرف وضعيه كل طفل وحاله كل طفل هل
العمل يتم ضمن منظمه او من ضمن العائله
الموسعه طبعا هناك مساعدات كبيره تدفقت
وهناك عدد من الاطفال الذين نقلوا الى
اسطنبول وايضا كان هناك
دول عتاب
تلقت هؤلاء ولكن يجب النظر عن كثب بحاله
كل طفل على حده لماذا في تركيا ولكن ماذا
عن الوضع في سوريا كيف يتم حمايه الاطفال
في سوريا لا سيما من فقدوا عائلاتهم
لسوء الحظ عدد كبير من الاطفال في سوريا
خسروا عائلاتهم في خلال السنوات التي عشره
الماضيه هذه عمليه حصلت لفتره طويله وهناك
اجراءات للتعامل مع هذا الموضوع هناك
الاستجابه على مستوى الامم المتحده والسيد
مارت تحدث وقال ان هناك خذلان في ايصال
المساعدات في بالنسبه الى سوريا وبالتالي
نحن نتحدث عن العبور والمعابر وهناك اليات
قائمه ولكنها لا تعمل بشكل جيد نحن لا
نزال بحاجه الى العمل طبعا هناك تركيز على
الطعام وعلى المعدات لمحاوله استخراج
واخراج الناس ولكن في الوقت نفسه يجب
التعامل مع الاطفال لكي نحافظ على الدعم
الاجتماعي والنفسي حول الاطفال لكي يتمكن
هؤلاء من التعامل مع هذه الكارثه اشكرك
جيمز دانزلو رئيس قسم المناصره بمنظمه
انقذوا الاطفال ضيفنا من لندن
معنا من عمان الدكتوره سهى طبال
الاستشاريه في علم النفس دكتوره سهى
الاثار النفسيه طبعا كبيره جدا وعلى يعني
شرائح مختلفه واعداد كبيره من الناس ولكن
دعينا نبدا بالناجين ما الاثار النفسيه
عليهم وهم نجوا من هذا الزلزال الهائل
وربما فقدوا افراد من عائلاتهم وعاشوا هذه
التجربه المخيفه
صحيح السلام عليكم متعازينا لذوي الشهداء
وان شاء الله بالسلامه
للناجين بالطبع طبعا احنا عم نحكي عن
التراب ما بعد الصدمه لا يؤثر فقط على
الكبار وانما على الاطفال
التهديد الحقيقي اللي عم بحسوا فيه
الاطفال لن يذهب بمجرد انتشارهم من تحت
الارض هم
التراب مع بعض الصب ما يستمر لفتره طويله
يعني صار هيك كما ذكر الاستاذ انه نحن
بحاجه للدعم النفسي الاجتماعي ما عدنا
نحكي فقط دعم نفسي لانه شعور الطفل
بالامان شعوره بعدم التهديد شعوره
بالاحتضان من من سواء اي احد من اقاربه
الانشطه الاجتماعيه اللاحقه ممكن تؤثر
ايجابا ومن ثم ياتي دور الدعم النفسي طبعا
الرد الفعل ما راح يبين في الوقت الحالي
على جراء الصدمه النفسيه لانه في كثير من
الاطفال ممكن في عندهم اصابات حاجتهم
للعلاجات مهمه جدا كجزء من الدعم النفسي
الاجتماعي حاجتهم ايضا للماكل للمامن
للملبس لحدا يحتضنهم يشعرهم بالامان
الاجتماعي شفنا كيف وهم عاملين
المنقذين كيف اللغه الايجابيه اللي كانوا
بيتعاملوا معهم فيها وصراحه شي بيرفع
الراس
بطريقه تعاملهم مع هؤلاء الاطفال وتطمينهم
هذا المطلوب في هذه المرحله المراحل
اللاحقه نحن بنعرف
التراب ما بعد الصدمه هو بيظهر كرد فعل
على التغيرات الكيميائيه في الدماغ بعد
التعرض لهاي الاحداث المؤلمه اثروا مش راح
يبين هلا هم في ناس كتير حواليهم وعم
بيدعموهم بالوقت الحالي عم بيعملوا لهم
مسكن عم بيطمنوهم حتى لو لا قدر الله
كانوا قد فقدوا الاب او الام ولكن في
طمانه حواليهم انه احتمال نلاقيهم لكن
الاحداث الصعبه حتكون
من الزمن ربما بعد شهر بعد التعافي خلينا
نقول
منحب على على الكبار ايضا سيده سهى هذه
يعني هذا هذا كله ينسحب ايضا على الكبار
ممن استطاعوا ان يخرجوا
جزء مش بسيط من كمان اللي موجودين في
تركيا هم من اللاجئين او من الناجحين
السوريين اللي مروا الكبار منهم بحدث
متتاليه على مدى عشر سنين ولكن بالنسبه
للاطفال الصغار هي خبره جديده خلينا نكون
واقعيين كثير منهم ولدوا بعد خلينا نقول
الحرب وهم في اوضاع اللجوء وهم نازحين قد
يكون بالنسبه للكبار تعرضوا للدعم النفسي
تعلموا اجراءات التعامل مع ما بعد التعامل
مع الحدث الصادم لاحظنا كمان تاثيراتهم
على اولادهم يعني اذا لاحظت كثير من
الاطفال عند انتشالهم اللي كانوا يردد اسم
الله اللي كان يقول انا راحت علي الصلاه
فيبدو انه الجيل السابق من من الكبار
اثروا بشكل او باخر على طريقه التنشئه في
تقبل ان اسالك فيما تبقى من وقت عن
العاملين في الانقاذ والاغاثه ايضا هؤلاء
لابد ان عملهم في هذا المجال في هذه
الكارثه تحديدا اثر له اثار نفسيه عليهم
ما هي وكيف يمكن معالجتها صحيح هذا الجزء
اساسي صراحه في التعامل حتى بالعلوم
الطبيه بشكل عام
وبالظروف الطوارئ الحاجه الى الدعم النفسي
نحن مش بس تقديم الدعم النفسي لهؤلاء
الافراد لابد من ان نطور مهارات ذاتيه
عندهم للدعم النفسي دعم النفسي يكون اما
بالتفريغ اخراج المشاعر هاي للخارج اما
بانه يحكي مع مع شخص اخر ممكن يكون اخصائي
نفسي او غير نفسي ولكن شخص يتحدث اليه
يشعر بالطمانينه له ممكن يكتب ما مره
المهم يطلع اللي جوا لابد ان يخرج من
سواء بالكتابه بالنسبه للاطفال مهم جدا
الرسم لانه كثير منهم صعب يعني انا اذكر
فيها بعد حالات اللجوء السوري في بعض
الاطفال
الاشهر ما كانوا يتكلموا لكن لما ان رسموا
وعبروا واخرجوا ما بداخلهم بسهوله صار في
عندهم تحسن في مهارات التواصل بشكل افضل
شكرا جزيلا لك سهى طبال الاستشاريه في علم
النفس ضيفتنا من عمان
قال وزير الامن الوطني الاسرائيلي اتمار
بن جزير ان المجلس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
الامنيه المصغر وافق على منح اعتراف رسمي
لتسع بؤر استطانيه اقيمت في الضفه الغربيه
المحتله كما قرر المجلس امداد عشرات البؤر
العشوائيه بشبكات الكهرباء والمياه والمضي
قدما في التصديق على مخططات وبناء الاف
الوحدات الاستيطانيه الجديده فالضفه
الغربيه المحتله وقال رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتانياهو ان الايام
المقبله ستشهد التصديق على بناء وحدات
سكنيه جديده في المستوطنات الموجوده في
الضفه الغربيه
ضفت الغربيه ايضا قتلت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي فتى
واصابت اثنين اخرين خلال اقتحامها مدينه
جنين ومخيمها ووقعت اشتباكات بين
الفلسطينيين وجنود الاحتلال الذين تسللوا
الى منطقه الجابريات المطله على مخيم جنين
واعتقلوا الاسير المحرر جبريل الزبيدي
شقيق الاسير زكريا الزبيدي بذريعه انه
مطلوب
قالت وسائل اعلام تونسيه ان سلطات الامن
اعتقلت الطيب راشد رئيس محكمه التعقيب
السابق والبشير العكرمي قاضي التحقيق
السابق وهو المكلف بملف اغتيال السياسيين
السياسيين المعارضين شكر بلعيد ومحمد
الابراهيمي وكان العكرمي اقيل من مهامه في
يونيو الماضي بمرسوم رئاسي بتهمه اخفاء
ادله في ملف اغتيال الاغتيال قبل ابطال
المحكمه الاداريه لاقالته وياتي ايقاف
العكرم وراشد بعد سلسله اعتقالات شملت
السياسي خيام التركي ورجل الاعمال كمال
لطيف والقيادي السابق بحرق كات النهضه عبد
الحميد الجلاصي دون صدور اي تعليق رسمي من
السلطات التونسيه
قال عضو جبهه الخلاص الوطني في تونس رضا
بلحاج ان الرئيس قيس سعيد يلهي المواطنين
بمشاكل جانبيه عبر الايقافات والمداهمات
على حد وصفه اضاف باب الحاج ان سعيد في
عزل في عزله وفي نهايه مرحلته على حد
تعبيره
قيس سعيد يتخبط في ازمته هو يريد تصدير
ازمته نحو تلهيه المواطنين بمشاكل جانبيه
لتغطيه الازمه الاقتصاديه الخانقه الازمه
السياسيه التي يعيشها بعد انهيار منظومته
في مناسبتين اثناء الانتخابات المناسبه
الاولى والدوره الثانيه
قال المحامي تونسي سمير ديلو ان المعلومات
المتوفره حول الايقافات الاخيره لعدد من
السياسيين استقيت من عائلات الموقوفين وان
عدد الايقافات مرشح للزياده اضاف ديلو ان
الايقافات قد يعود سببها الى نشاطات
واجتماعات سياسيين معارضين
المعطيات المتوفره لحد الان هي التي
استقاها المحامون من عائلات المعنيين وهو
عدد مرشح للزياده ولكن اغلب المتداول
اعلاميا لا علاقه له بالواقع هي مجرد
تخمينات والامر في تقديرنا يتعلق بنشاط
سياسي عادي اتصالات بين معارضين ولكن
تقديرنا ايضا هو ان السلطه مازالت في نهج
الهروب الى الامام من خلال تقديم فديه
للراي العام لانهائه عن اشكالياته
السياسيه والاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
ننتقل الان الى جمله من اخبار الرياضه مع
الزميل المعز بولحيه